Thats USC football player Zach
Banner.
I wanted to show him a good
time.
First up. Complying with the
NCAA rule that states
that states that athletes
may only be paid from a job.
So I made Zach my employee.
Boss.
Listen, man,
as my employee,
I wanted to gift you.
So I got you a car.
- Ooh...
- I couldn't buy it.
- Oh, man.
- 'Cause that's against
the rules of the NCAA.
- Correct.
- So I rented it.
- For me?
- Yeah, now how old are you?
- 23.
- I think you gotta be
older than that
to drive the car,
based on their rules,
on NCAA.
Just Maserati rules.
- Are you gonna drive me?
- I'm gonna chauffeur you, brah.
- You're a senior,
headed towards the draft.
- Yes, sir.
- How are you feeling right now
about this--your whole career
as a college athlete?
- Feeling good, man.
I was All-American this year.
- Okay.
- Everything with the Rose Bowl
victory and everything.
We brought SC back,
put it on the map.
- What was the night like
after that game?
- Oh, insane.
Dudes were jumping off tables
doing crazy stuff?
- So I mean, that's pretty much
what you get paid in.
Is party, and fan love.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we get paid in parties
and girls at school.
- Girls at school?
- Yeah.
It's like one of those type of
things, if I told you,
I'd have to kill you
type things.
- Don't stop spilling the tea
now, Zach, it's too late!
You already out here
dry snitching.
Dry snitching is when you snitch
but kind of.
- What's the brokest moment
you've had in college?
- One time during the summer,
I was straight up eatin' Cup of
Noodles for, like, three days.
- Cup of Noodles?
- Cup of Noodles for breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
- Ugh!
Man, you need to be living life.
You need to be eating
Wagyu steak.
You know what that is?
- No.
- That's where they treat
the cow like a king.
They massage it.
They--and the cattle
watch M. Night Shyamalan
movies and Scorsese flicks.
- They cater to the cow.
And then they kill it,
so you go the best meat.
- It's like a black woman.
- What?
- Yeah.
- It's like a black woman.
- What?
- Yeah.
- What, 'cause they have
the best meat?
- No, 'cause they cater to them
and they kill you at the end
when they found out you hanging
out with they boyfriends.
- Too many blitzes, [BLEEP].
Too many blitzes.
[scatting]
- They got good food here?
- They got dope food here, man,
that's why we here.
Catch the keys.
- Oh!
I missed--oh, man!
- I can't really purchase
your food.
Cheers to the rules, right?
Mmm.
Uh-oh.
Look at Zach's face
staring at that steak.
DJ Khaled and another one.
And another one.
Thank you, man.
So what's your normal day like
as a college athlete?
- Up at 6:00 a.m. for lift.
School starts at 8:30,
get out of class around 2:00.
Meetings are at 3:30
and then practice is at 5:00
and we're done about 8:00.
- Phew. How often
do you skip class?
- Every day.
- Like, not all your classes.
- No.
- But there's...
- You choose.
- Every day there's one4 class
that you're just not gonna make.
- No.
- If you weren't
as good as you are,
would you have to go to
more classes?
- Yeah, 'cause then you're
supposed to carry the team GPA.
- Uh-huh.
- The average amongst the team.
- So what's the kicker's GPA?
- Well, he's a kicker, so he
doesn't really practice often.
And he's white,
so it's pretty high.
- How does it make you feel,
Zach, to be an athlete
and know that people
are making money off you?
- It's just not fair.
I simply think that
the players should be
compensated.
People from the NCAA,
people from the school,
coaches,
everybody's getting paid;
why aren't we?
- What I might do,
get this to go, and then go.
And accidentally leave it.
What's the phrase,
finders-keepers?
- That's still illegal.
We can't do that.
- You right, you right.
I now decree this leftovers.
They have no cash value.
Let me say it again.
Fans might be watching.
These are leftovers!
No cash value!
I don't want this shit no more!
By the rules of the NCAA,
you can eat that food, right?
- Yeah, yeah, I can do that.
- Then go to town, man.
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah.
Does it taste like freedom?
- Really good steak.
- Look at you, man,
sitting here,
eating someone else's trash.
How'd it get like this, Zach?
I came, I saw,
and I balled out with Zach.
As much as the NCAA rules
would allow.
- You the man, James.
- You the man too.
[BLEEP] Cup of Noodles.